the guy bought $117 case of Pinot Grigio
right so $10 a bottle Pinot Grigio I go
in his Twitter account on this flight
and all he's tweeting is the following
Jay Cutler I love you Jay Cutler you're
the best Jay Cutler I'm mad at you he's
a huge for those that don't know Jay
Cutler was is and wasn't I'm the
quarterback of the Chicago Bears right
so he's talking about Jay Cutler Jay
Cutler so I call the call my my my point
person back of the story I said look I
want you to go to Ebay and I want you to
buy him a signed Jay Cutler Jersey which
was like $350 much more than the eight
percent profit we made on the hundred
eleven dollar case of Pinot Grigio and I
want you to send a note in there and say
thank you for your order
thanks for shopping Wine Library so
great so I send it and then three and a
half weeks go by and nothing happens and
I'm like this son of a gun is really not
gonna acknowledge this random kindness
so you know we send out some other stuff
and then out of nowhere I'm actually
ironically I'm about to take stage at a
talk in Las Vegas and I get a phone call
from Kristin and she goes I mean she
hasn't called me yet she works in the
thank you Department doesn't really need
me she's only to call me about these
couple of things we sent out and I pick
up the phone I go you got something she
goes kind of I go go ahead she goes I
want to read you the order we just got
so she reads off this order and how many
people here into wine but great Wow
amazing
so this person who orders 4800 dollars
worth of high-end red burgundy you know
coach three like do Jack like real stuff
for the real nerds in here anyway and
here's what the comment box said it said
hey my name is Craig once you know you
guys sent my friend John a Chicago Bears
Jersey and he told me the story and
that's how I found out about ups you
have great prices on red burgundy PSS
I'm a huge Bruce Springsteen fan the the
punchline of that story is you guys are
curating events and experiences that
really matter
people today more and more as time goes
on are sharing more and more information
about themselves we can cry about
privacy but every day we prove with our
actions that we don't care right and
really there's a much more fascinating
debate over that which is that people
are inherently good the mainstream media
just talks about the small 1% of bad and
that's why we share our privacy your
ability to know a lot more about the
people that are coming to these events
is far greater than you may believe and
that if you actually put the time to
understand who that is I promise you
this that if I came to one of your
events as a top seller or executive and
I walked into my hotel room and instead
of a fruit basket or a bottle of wine or
a nice welcome note that there was an
ear of Jets hat that would
because that would show the thing that
matters more than anything which is
intent and effort